final preparations for dinner at
Tartuffe Ian friends this restaurant in
Frankfurt is the latest under the brand
name here every dish is seasoned with
truffles head chef alessandro cocoa used
to live in london he believes that
Frankfurt's diners are similar to
Londoners who will pay good money for
good quality beautiful city is really
quite different from a London but Sri
international not far from the
restaurant an apartment viewing Stephan
Keller is helping Britons move they're
coming to frankfurt to work and live
after the UK leaves the european union
this 260 square metre apartment costs
about four thousand euros a month it's
perfect for someone from London he says
things that this is a bargain when you
compare it to London and consider the
urban location this is much cheaper
Frankfurt has plenty of office space to
around a million square meters are
standing empty and new residential
property is being built in the historic
city centre the biggest problem is the
reputation of the city on the river mine
Londoners see Frankfurt is old-fashioned
and simple the city is looking to change
that this area is anything but boring
you might have to discover a few things
on your own but you have to give the
city and the region a chance there's a
lot going on here Stephan Keller also
tries to make it clear to prospective
buyers that Frankfurt is not cut off
from the world
the surrounding area includes Wiesbaden
where there's an international school
and Oberoi's allowed home book and kunuk
stein so there's a lot more to living in
Frankfurt than just downtown many
international banks run major operations
from here and some of them are
considering moving their European
headquarters to Frankfurt after all the
European Central Bank is based here and
the region could get an extra ten
thousand financial jobs according to
other advocates of Frankfurt that
a lot for a city that some 62,000
bankers already call home because
entrances of one I mean you could say
we're a mini London at a ratio of ten to
one and that makes things easy for
companies thinking about relocating to
Frankfurt they don't have to jump
through hoops licenses are here offices
are here it's relatively easy to switch
operations to Frankfurt to unhear falaka
at Tartuffe Ian's friends the staff
knows that in the future not only
Germans will be coming here but plenty
of new Frankfurt residents from across
the channel too